was that an earthquake that's my land
was it dragon
hey youtubers it's Charlie since
hopefully you guys have all had a chance
to see that fire and death that is
desolation of smaug let's talk about how
awesome it is
I mean wait no do a totally unbiased
review we finally got a good look at
Smaug voiced by the always amazing
Benedict Cumberbatch and the true
villain was finally revealed just as
things went from bad to worse BAM slam
to black and it's gonna be another year
before we get to see the finale so let's
do our top ten moments and then I'll do
my review careful for spoilers if you
haven't read the books or you haven't
seen the movie yet number 10 the spiders
of Mirkwood this was actually my
strongest memory of reading The Hobbit
as a child the spiders are way more
scary than Smaug they weren't as big or
legendary as she lived in the two towers
but I did think it was interesting that
Bilbo only heard them speaking whenever
he was wearing the ring number nine
Bilbo's precious The Hobbit is Bilbo's
tale so he's really the hero of the
story and as much as he's grown as a
character a lot of it he owes to his
courage I mean his precious when he
first uttered those words after killing
that spider I just got chills number 8
the treasure hoard when people in the
Lord of the Rings talk about the famous
wealth of the dwarves the treasure hoard
is what they're referring to and just to
give you an idea of the scale of it
Smaug is about 145 feet long and the
pile makes him look like a dwarf number
7 the witch King's tomb it wasn't
totally explicit but the tomb that
Gandalf and radagast Medan was the tomb
of the witch-king of Angmar
remember he gets killed by a Owen and
Return of the King but it's probably one
of the most evil places in middle-earth
and it was totally awesome
number six bard the Bowman so FAR's big
moment doesn't really come to the next
film but his redemption is very similar
to aragorn's his father was actually the
king of dáil remember that city that got
destroyed by Smaug outside of the Lonely
Mountain the Black Arrow he has is going
to be very important in that next movie
number 5 Orlando Bloom and Evangeline
Lilly as a huge fan of the Lord of the
Rings it was really fun to see Orlando
Bloom again in this film he's a lot
younger and a lot meaner his fight
scenes were so acrobatic it was almost
like he was dancing his dance partner
Evangeline Lilly was also a welcome
addition to the story she wasn't in the
original book but Peter Jackson editor
to kind of keep it from turning into a
sausage fest turns out not a lot of
women in The Hobbit number 4 Gandalf at
dalgo door this came at the climax of
the film but watching Gandalf pull out
his sword and March
right into the trap was so much fun if
you didn't know before then this was
actually the biggest surprise of the
movie that the necromancer that was
living there actually turned out to be
Sauron who was also voiced by Benedict
Cumberbatch he's not as powerful as he
will be during Lord of the Rings but the
fight with Gandalf was this amazing
visual effects sequence in Lord of the
Rings Gandalf actually uses a lot of
magic but it's never really shown
visually in the way it is during the
Hobbit I think the only reason for that
is just because their visual effects
budget on those films was much smaller
number three the barrel chase mark my
words this will be a theme park right at
some point the fight scenes / flume ride
was one of the best action sequences of
the film
it not only showcases the synchronicity
of the dwarves fighting style and the
way they work together
it also gives Orlando Bloom a chance to
dance his way down the river number 2
Smaug the Magnificent as expected
Benedict Cumberbatch totally killed it
as Smaug if you couldn't tell they use
motion capture on his face to get all
the expressions right but if you really
want to relive it without going back to
the theatre just listen to an episode of
Sherlock with your eyes closed from a
visual standpoint the way they shot
Smaug was also really cool whenever his
face got really close to the camera they
use this awesome tilt shift effect to
make it look like your field of vision
wasn't quite big enough to get his
entire face into focus and my number one
moment the Forge battle so this combined
the amazing teamwork of the dwarves that
you saw during that barrel ride along
with the performance of the Dragon raise
your hand if your favorite moment of
this fight scene was actually when Smaug
caught sight of the golden statue and
just froze like a dog staring at a piece
of steak it was almost like the gold was
making him high my honorable mentions
were barons house seeing Peter Jackson
and then seeing the inn of the Prancing
Pony again best dive bar and all of
middle-earth so let me know what your
favorite moments were in the comments
below I'm sure most of them evolved
Benedict Cumberbatch so overall I really
like this film a lot more than the first
film obviously they're both amazing but
the way they paced this film was much
tighter the action was better the
characters were much more complex so I
was much more emotionally invested in
what was going on on-screen and in that
way it actually became a much more fun
experience sitting in the theatre or
watching it for the first time there
were a lot of visual references to two
towers that were really awesome - I'm
sure you guys caught a lot of them -
like there were the lighting of the
spires the flames along with the spies
watching bay Oren's house there was the
fight with the spiders the fight with
Sheila and then there were the two
towers dog adore and the Lonely Mountain
I consider Lonely Mountain
at our I try not to compare the Hobbit
trilogy to Lord of the Rings too much
but there are a lot of people who are
saying that from a literary perspective
The Hobbit just isn't quite deep enough
to match the scope of Lord of the Rings
you can kind of make your own opinion
about that but it's totally not gonna
stop me from buying the blu-ray or going
to see it again in the theatres and I
totally love the film I give it a solid
a it's my favorite holiday movie of the
year so far so I've got a bunch more
videos coming out this weekend I'm
working on under the Walking Dead Q&A as
well as the Game of Thrones video I have
a big update for all the anime I'm gonna
be doing next year that I'll post this
weekend be sure to subscribe to get
everything right now you can actually
click here to get my recent Doctor Who
Q&A and you can click here to get my
top-10 anticipated moments or next year
on The Walking Dead thank you so much
for watching everybody go see The Hobbit
high fives